personally i tend to trust elon musk
more than anyone who works for the
administration including this black
lesbian and right now we don't see a
recession right now that is not we're
not in a recession right now uh right
now we're in a transition where we will
we are uh going to go into a place of
stable and steady growth and that's
going to be uh that's that's going to be
our focus
guys it's a transition
it's pride month and everybody's
transitioning so if you're not
transitioning from being a boy to a girl
at least we'll transition the economy
all right so look they're obviously
going to use this as cover for the
recession so once the recession hits
they will say oh no it is because kovid
is back uh let's not forget that joe
biden just this is about two two and a
half months ago was blaming the pandemic
for inflation not printing all the money
that he was doing i want every american
to know that i'm taking inflation
uh
very seriously and it's my top for
domestic priority
and i'm here today to talk about
solutions and there's going to be more
we're going to have to talk about as
well
but first i want us to be crystal clear
about the problem
there are two
leading causes of inflation we're seeing
today
the first cause of inflation is a once
in a century pandemic
not only did it shut down our global
economy it threw the supply chains and
demand completely out of whack
especially in countries where more
effective recovery responses
weren't available
okay so it's not the printing of the
money it's not the lockdowns and all of
those things right it's the pandemic
itself right uh it's not what they did
in reaction to the pandemic it's the
pandemic itself and of course putin is
the other thing right it's always putin
in the pandemic you give me a p word and
it's a p word man i'll tell you
um so this is they're telling us right
like they're they're the reason i'm
doing the show the way i'm doing it
today is because i want you guys to see
it as they're about to do it they're now
warning us part two is coming and
they're telling us that the first time
the economy was banged up was because of
covid1 so do you think they're gonna do
this thing again of course uh here's joe
biden back in february talking about how
things are actually better but it's your
problem because you've got psychological
problems you freak
is a phenomenal negative psychological
impact
that covet has had on the public
psyche
and so you have an awful lot of people
who are
not withstanding the fact that uh
that things have gotten so much better
for them economically
uh that they are thinking but how do you
get up in the morning feeling happy
happy that everything's all right
deep breath dave
deep breath
guys um
there's been a mass psychological
problem so i actually will agree with
joe biden on that i don't think it's the
psychological problem that he thinks it
is but there is a mass psychological
problem it's people that believe his
nonsense it's people that are still
buying into the covet stuff all it's all
the npc people and okay you get it all
on all of that uh but this idea that you
have so much more money that things are
so great but it's you have a
psychological condition you have some
you wake up and you're depressed and you
don't know why you have a little cartoon
cloud floating over your head and if
only you will take celexa or bellatron
or some other drug which then of course
gives you the diarrhea and the bloating
and the thoughts of suicide and the
other stuff then you would realize that
joe biden is actually doing a hell of a
job
but
you know we must give the devil as due
and since they're telling us what
they're going to do how can we prepare
to be aware of it when they do it and
when are they going to do it well of
course a lot of this is going to drop
right before the election because this
is going to get us to a male and voting
situation and all of the craziness
around that